haben eine vollkaskomentalität in
deutschland meine ich schon immer etwas
mit links soll der staat zur seite
stehen und der stadt macht das sehr
gerne bei der stadt hat liebe abhängige
untertan als freie bürger wir haben mit
die höchste steuer und abgabenquote in
der ganzen welt glaubt nur belgien ist
in europa noch vor uns einen staat der
immer nur scheinbar gibt gibt gibt
bräuchten wir ein staat der viel viel
nehmen weniger nimmt wenn wir nämlich
eine geringere abgabenquote geringere
steuern für alle geringere
mehrwertsteuer auf obst getreide und
gemüse ein höheren steuerlast
pauschbetrag um für das alter vorsorgen
zu können et cetera pp dann wären wir
alle wieder freie bürger wir könnten
mehr verantwortung übernehmen wir können
mehr für unser alter für uns zur
nächsten zu lieben vorsorgen und wir
während weniger in diese abhängigkeit
allerdings der staatsschutz diese
vollkaskomentalität weil er eben gerne
die gouvernante ist die ampel steht und
dem deutschen michel die nacht kappe ins
gesicht zieht